so I've got seven days to buy a house in
the United States of America
using none of my own money Oh Terrance
and I speak the sword is prepared to
give it ours man I mean uncommon I'll go
freakin supposed to do confirm with them
every 15 minutes
thanks for nothing
we have a lease option on it and then he
has a renter rent
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah yeah yeah what would be the most
you could accept to live with and what
do you think obviously I need to do
something to my what were the lowest you
can accept and still live with it's hard
because there's a lot of properties that
are really really cheap if we want it
cash and we just went for it
Milly's although sometimes 74 we point
on performance
60s without the defend you sixty-nine
lights over the logo 65-63 system on
that or 69 over 60 is that this up is up
because as low as you're pretty close to
if we did 1601 but asking you to pay for
the transfer fees and stuff that work
for you
he's trying to play with numbers if you
paid 69 and I could contribute 3% okay
so you're basically saying if we bought
in 69
you got off something if you're really
really serious about it right okay if I
pay the closing costs or anything right
let's do 86 catch everything pay the
closing costs
I'll pay the transfer tax if I don't
would it take from the top needs to be
going out
the movie you could do it next week well
that's quite cool that's quite cool
lease option agreement will either pay
the price that you want but on our terms
or we'll pay the price that we want but
on your terms of fun so if we might
listen cash tomorrow yeah
we've more like a bit about a bit of our
work in essays by bit did by occasional
attacks whatsoever
yeah interesting
yeah cap cares yeah this is weekend
given that they'll maybe give you watch
65,000 yeah and then we've been
completely financed into you and that
your offer because ever set up trying
but home to other projects at the same
time the benefit long is we would do the
beefed up in the house and if we if you
never hear from us again you've got a
silly we thought price that's a pocket
always easily say we go to the bank take
out three grand
fix everything up put tenants back in it
you know it's a plus one three better no
I can have a guy come here tomorrow take
this back in this whole floor for me and
then start painting on Saturday for at
least nine hundred dollars in five years
how much do you think this place we want
oh [ __ ] five years
like I said they want a common face no
more than that easy work that yeah you
want 65 yeah
would you be up for any sort of deal any
sort of arrangement or any sort of deal
with perhaps we come to our new try a
higher amount but not straight away it's
a Mike riddle no I'm not ready to like
at least one so like maybe I know 85
wait five hundred a thousand in three
years but in the meantime what we'll do
is we will essentially be your tenant
will give you a monthly rent will give
you eight five thousand four in three
years
no red one your foot now I know it's
early
no no just to see what lobby walking me
that do the same thing I'm like not just
drink air because my team to do I think
the cash hmm goodbye more yeah if you
got a really good deal on this the cash
like a really good deal yeah well we'd
have to Christmas that orange to know
for sure but if we got it like after 20
at least 20 22 25 ask it like it 150 150
why would you why would you 255 but then
not 85 in three years you don't use the
moment yeah and then we know why that
you'd be prepared to do a completion do
that because I have
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he was just standing in the middle of
the road look what the heck is he doing
he looked like you wanted to kill me
[Music]
yeah duration like okay no so basically
he's open to the idea of us taking on
his mortgage and everything like we
talked about but he's just got a couple
of concerns and what's to make sure it's
done properly I totally get that that's
cool so what do you mean are you are you
around you want to join or maybe meet
and just go through all the different
ifs and buts and I can talk you through
we can I mean I don't know what you want
to do okay yeah I mean we were just
leaving
Camden it's a bit of it's not being
great so I think this property would be
a lot better I guess we could probably
be there about half hour yeah calling
forty minutes just in case because it
just in case traffic but yeah that's
great and we can have a chat and see
what happens
so would you do it
would you just text me the address again
because I can't remember the exact
address and I'm just we're just in the
car and stuff at the moment if you text
me the address and and we'll be there in
next 40 minutes I appreciate that man
you're awesome I'll see you in 40
minutes
cheers bro bye bye oh dude I think we're
gonna get a deal yeah so what's the plan
how far is it for me to the problems
ahead it should be really really hope
that we don't miss this appointment
listen hold on me well that's what did
he say the concerns will were the
telephones so if we can put his concern
is that we're gonna bugger off back to
UK he turns from the trashed place and I
grab you never hears from us again
okay we need to meet him if this if we
get the agent inside that guy we can 1
billion percent do this I think I mean
if we can get Mervyn on our side yeah
if Mervyn wants this deal to happen it
will happen because the seller is
motivated so we need to go over and get
him on side big time maybe uh let me do
the talking
I get why but that means to come on we
can afford it I think the thing is what
so so what's the crack then what's you
actually so we happy to do early so
concern about everything else
the tendons and the you know that the
year the five years you know he's open
to him and I still you know a decade
obviously so well I his mortgage
pleasures his mortgage treatment is
roughly just it's two hundred dollars a
month so that's what it is that you're
selling right yes okay that's cool what
she what she's main concern was main
concern is just the duration I mean
that's the biggest thing the duration of
the deal can you get a little extra yeah
so I get that okay if we said table give
a few thousand hundred for right they
will pay him 200 per month to cover is
more which and then in five years we'll
give him seventy five thousand pound
what he will he be up for that like 350
next 150 bucks long oh he's gonna get
that back in the first he's gonna get
two grand in the first year he's gonna
get an extra it's six seven runs mm-hmm
what are you giving the gal at this deal
if we do this how are you gonna get paid
oh well the field that I have to give
would have to be negotiated and to
negotiate anything about that markup
would be my fee or you guys can pay me
on the society even if that's something
you're open to but usually if there's an
assignment of these types of deals
that's typically the traditional way but
basically and what you're saying is you
would like potentially something up
front from us
you know how much money waving a knife
up this day if he goes off
well we know the Lorraine is approached
to make well you tell us you told us 8
to 12 yes that we've confirmed with
other people this other make neighbors
know that my family is basically we're
paying him to depends a month we will
win it out and we'll make that property
difference and then in five years this
property will point it with a lot more
than tell me five yeah and then when we
play him 75 will obviously be able to
cash in the difference we can even sell
it at the end of the term if you want to
see if we say if we said to him he's
never doing the extraction before we've
done if we say to him we'll take it over
the mortgage payments will be the person
that makes everything happen and where
he kept all of the cash flow all of it
so anything above 300 200 well we said
we're gonna give 350 okay we have
thought because we don't only be in 2000
no there's no no because he that 2000
pound was really for him yeah yes 100%
100% so if we give the vendor also we
leave him to own this because if he
overs this he'll make it happen he
didn't care what happen cuz we can't
speak to Sarah be with ya if we say to
him look we'll help you and teach you
what a lease option is right
you pay the owner 200 bucks a month
anything above that you keep but you're
responsible with that money for the
maintenance of the property but then at
the end of the time we have the option
to buy it this is the most complicated
agreement a bucket a sphere yeah yeah
yeah we have a lease option on it and
then yeah we'll have the option to buy
is upstairs and then you married kids
where did you live with okay how much
money to make come on hold on
on average okay how much the boy this is
how much you made last month
okay so basically it's been slow because
you only get paid when you make a deal
right have you ever thought about
managing properties managing them
you're just open to making money right
and learning new things
uh-huh okay here's the thing if we buy
this problems you're on a lease option
agreement we will make really good cash
flow every single month okay the problem
it is with from our point of view is
we're not we're not in the area which is
also a problem for the owner because
he's thinking all these guys aren't in
the area
what happens if there's bad tenants
doesn't make sense we're suggesting that
we buy on an option but you manage it
and you keep 100% of the cash flow 100%
so listen we pay the landlord 200 bucks
a month
the owner okay then you rent it out how
much would you rent this place out for
as it is good so you pay him 200 you
keep 800 and I mean you might have to
pay some costs and stuff but any profit
you make you keep 100% and then in five
years
we'll buy it for 75 grand that'll be our
option to buy it and then you can
continue managing it for us and we'll
give you a percentage of the rent
probably but that's five years you'll be
a millionaire by then I'll be a
millionaire by then I don't know what do
you think okay you need to speak to the
owner you need to tell him we'll pay
them 200 bucks a month will bite the
75,000 pounds in five years I'll give
you all the contracts and stuff to do
that which he can sign I'll also send
you another memorandum of understanding
which we can sign which is what I
basically just told you like the bullet
points of this conversation and the
agreement and you can sign it will sign
it then you get that if you can get the
seller on board you be sure you should
be making at least three four hundred
bucks a month and just just for managing
it
let's do it done let's do it Dale man
dude you're freaking awesome awesome
absolutely stoked we just sent over the
contract to Marvin the broker he has
sent it back the deal has been agreed
and tomorrow morning we are flying back
from New York to London England what a
week
what a week you know what it's been an
incredible incredible journey I hope
that you managed to make sense of what
was going on so basically we are buying
the house on a no-money-down lease
option agreement but the estate agent he
is going to be managing it and taking
control of it and benefiting from the
cash flow it's the perfect joint venture
where also we spoke to Marvin we're
going to be doing more deals with him
and he's learnt so much he's so inspired
he's now going to be looking to do some
lease option agreement himself you know
what just blows it on the line but I
think the lesson in this is not that I
fantastic not at all I actually was a
bit of a dummy of this week the real
lesson is that was the right knowledge
and the right gritty determination any
body can make money in the property
industry anywhere in the world you just
need to take action get the knowledge
and go do it Wow
look at this well we did it
I can't believe that we did it but we
did it
what a day to be alive
[Music]
[Music]
to think when did we found we found you
just from zillow and now we're doing
business together so this is gonna be on
YouTube are you okay with that are you
okay to go on YouTube oh man you know
what we're really killing it in the UK
okay we're here my name is Samuel Samuel
Leeds my name yeah yeah we're killing it
in the UK we came to the state we've no
money yeah yeah you just basically on a
on a challenge to try and do a deal with
no mama and if it wasn't for you we
wouldn't have been able to do this deal
so you are the friggin man no no no but
you know what this is this is awesome
and I can't wait to do business with ya
so you're we'll just imagine like what's
called a memorandum or sale to go it's
basically just so it just lays like what
we've agreed you present that to the
degree you send those will be your
contracts bioscience on their doctors on
and that's what you do anyway yeah then
you sign them in the vendor Center and
then we send them to the yeah it's my
English it's my English / so once we've
got their beefs once I will sign outside
give it to the owner Hugh sign it and
then we can put them in touch with the
is this is this like the strangest
agreement you've ever made going forward
you're gonna be responsible for pitting
tenants in here okay advertising it
collecting the rent you can do that
corner
you're gonna keep the rain you don't
have to pee Samuel any rent the only
thing you're gonna need to pay obviously
just the basic as it no it's gonna be as
if you own the property the mean to this
I'm pilot umpire D and buy them expand
in the rain every month just maybe maybe
just keep the box by I mean yeah that's
cool man do or something thank you
I appreciate this opportunity this is
awesome you're all some breath company
UK man yeah come to UK nine thank you so
much I appreciate your business
I look forward to working with you I
look forward to it man we'll be in touch
I'm training a dog my friend
[Music]